exactly all right
everybody so i'm thomas i'm i'm senior
debt scientist
a company called quantum black and today
I want to talk about how you can
actually get better model performance
with less data and reason I want to talk
to you about this is because so my firm
is a consulting firm so I deal a lot
with a non-technical like stakeholders
and they always come to me and say hey
Thomas so I have like 20 30 40 different
like data sources scattered around my
business landscape
can you please connect all the pieces
together and tell me how all of that
relates to this one single variable that
I'm actually interested in if you follow
that guideline you kind of end up with
really bloated models and very
complicated situations and what I what I
find is that a lot of a lot of to think
that more data is actually always better
and I think in a sense this is true
especially when you think about the
number of samples it with more samples
we can learn more but I'm personally not
so convinced that this is always the
case when we think about the number of
features the number of variables you
have in a dataset and I don't actually
think this belief it's just it is just
that non-technical people think this I
actually think like in in in our line of
work they designed a lot of data
scientists tend to think like this as
well I unfortunately don't have my exact
link here but I think a week or two ago
I was reading this blog reading a blog
post from some prominent engineering
team and they were basically discussing
like they were talking about how to
build their model and they basically
said yeah and when we did feature
engineer we created as many features as
possible so that we can allow the model
to learn as as all the complex relations
that are actually present in the data
sense and I mean this may or may not be
true but I think people that people have
worked with me will know that I tend to
be a very skeptical data scientist and I
think that as a community I think we
tend to think that machine learning
algorithms are you know smart
sophisticated algorithms but I actually
think like you can fool them very very
easily and and it is because because and
I mainly because of two two reasons I
think it's sometimes easy to for
algorithms what the first reason is
feature collinearity so
there's a lot of like you have a very if
you have a very big data set with many
many variables you'll find all kinds of
weird correlations a I think the chances
are high you'll find all kinds of weird
correlations and these correlations tend
to trip up your models and another thing
is scarce ins of data if you the thing
is these like these kind of like weak
correlations if I can call them that you
can't your models can detect them but
you typically meet a lot a lot of wall
of data to actually like be able to to
really measure those kind of like really
really weak correlations between between
those variables in your target variable
so scarce ins of data it's also a reason
of why it's not always a good idea to
always put just build as many features
as you can think of and plug that into a
model so really what I want to do today
is besides convincing you that it's
sometimes a good idea to do feature
section also talk a little bit about how
you can do features in feature selection
and our I will go into the details of
some algorithms and also highlights like
some open source like Python
implementations that are out there so
that it's very actually what amazed what
I want to show to you all is that it's
actually very easy to do this and it's
almost a shame if you not do this as
part of your model development process
but really to just like highlight the
the the reasons of why why it's good to
do why it's good to do feature selection
I think one reason is very is very
simple less features means you have less
data to process and therefore the
computational burden your learning
algorithm imposes is is less so that so
that's that's a good thing as well the
second thing is already what about what
I sort of talked about just a minute ago
is to reduce the risk of overfitting
like during feature selection limiting
yourself to a good set of base variables
will help you to reduce the noise in
your data set and therefore allow your
model to learn to properly pick up on
the right relationships that are present
in your data and finally this may or may
not matter in
your use case but in my use cases
typically matters a lot because I deal
with stakeholders that want to
understand what their models are
learning if you have fewer variables in
your data set it will make it easier to
explain like actually watcher 1 what
you're doing and 2 is secondly what your
model is actually learning so that's not
like why I think why I think features
why it actually pays off to do feature
selection so let's think about these
feature selection algorithms right like
what what do we really want from an from
from an algorithm so I just want to like
highlight highlight that here I think
this slide really I think this actually
like speaks for itself and we all kind
of know what we want out of this but
really a feature selection algorithm
should first and foremost remove
variables that contain absolutely no
information that is relevant to your
target variable but but secondly it
should also reduce the overlap in
information in between the variables
that is that you actually select in a
sense that I can have two identical
copies of a variable and if I have a
very if you have a feature selection
method that just looks at one variable
and and tries to measure like how
relevant is to target that was like both
variables but they're the same so they
don't contain any extra information so
you would prefer they still want to
remove one of those two so that's what
that's what really what I mean with with
the second one and and I feel why I
think this is important is is because
like what you see that what what I've
seen a lot is when people actually do
feature selection they you know they
maybe they tend to be like look it's
what's available and Psyche learn a
cycler actually has some good feature
selection algorithms out there but a lot
of them are univariate feature selection
methods and what I mean with that is
that they only look at the relationship
between a covariant and the target
variable in isolation and I don't think
this is necessarily a good idea because
because and I and I have like two short
examples to like really like to get
these points across if even if two
variables on their own do not have a
strong relationship with the target
variable combining them might actually
give you something that does allow you
to to explain your your independent your
target variable and secondly even if two
variables are highly correlated with
each other that does not necessarily
mean that the
that the that there's absence of what's
called variable complementarity and just
to and just to really like Joe let
message home I have to very like simple
dummy examples but at but it does show
they see what's happening so this is a
scatter plot matrix of two variables so
if you look at the histograms of each
variable you may see in the top left
corner this variables on so like pretty
much useless to to to really separate
your target variable and the second one
sort of separates the two classes but
you know but we demand completely
separate them so again just a simple
example to show that two variables that
on their own can not completely separate
the variable can combine separate the
target variable so this is one reason to
to not only consider univariate methods
but multivariate methods and the same
and the same for my second point around
that high variable correlation does not
mean the absence of that of information
but again combining them allows you to
completely separate separate the class
so really like two simple to just two
examples that that I wanted to show to
really illustrate that it pays it it
pays off to not only look at univariate
methods but at multivariate feature
selection methods so so what I want to
do today is basically go through this
through this diagram because roughly
speaking you can divide feature
selection algorithms in sort of three
categories in and these categories are
called wrapper methods filter methods
and embedded methods and I want to go
through these three key method methods
should quickly explain what is what
these methods are and give an example of
a given instance of like 'yo of an
algorithm that falls into these three
classes but I'll be I'll be coming back
to this slide and basically what I
wanted
I want to sort of fill it in as we as we
go along and I want to start with the
what I call the wrapper method so what
what do what do rapper Method 2 do
basically what the record methods does
it is there's there's a learning
algorithm and you give the learning as
always you give to learning algorithm a
bunch of features and you basically
decision as to whether you keep a set of
features or not it's purely based on the
performance of that model on some kind
of holdout set or some kind of cross
validation procedures you have in place
so an example of this would be you
having maybe like like a little just
like a logistic regression you measure
the performance on a holdout set and you
just you just you just do multiple
iterations and in every iteration you
feed a new set of different to configure
a different set of variables into the
model and you just keep the set that
results in the highest highest
performance so it's a very performance
based measure basically it's really
saying okay given the learning algorithm
what are the variables that give me the
highest performance let's just keep
those that's that's the gist of it so
you know sounds pretty straightforward
and again like if you if you if you look
in if you if you look around and get up
you'll find like open source
implementations this is it's straight
it's it's actually like really
straightforward to implement this
yourself like what I just described is
more like an exhaustive search strategy
where you try as many combinations of
features as possible and see which one
works best but you actually can use
different methods here like so there's
this there's this package called ml
extends and basically a number of it
one of them is s-class and which
basically stands for sequential forward
search so that is just like one you know
one where all the time we add the
variable that had that that we think
gives us the the better the most
performance gain to our a set of
selected variables but as you can see
and this is the and almost all of the
examples that I'm discussing will have
this sort of like scikit-learn
like API so it's very easy to just take
these modules and plug them into your
existing existing model estimation
pipeline which you can see here as well
sorry so that so these are just wrapper
methods like purely performance based
which variables give me the best
performance on some kind of holdout set
so which is which is really its main
advantage like if you really care about
performance this is probably going to
give you like the the best feature set
but there are some disadvantages in the
sense that one it is specific to the
learning algorithm you actually use and
to your app might reprimand is typically
estimate a new model and a new model for
every like configuration of the
variables you're trying so the
computational burden is actually like
pretty big especially if you think about
you having very large data sets or you
wanting to try also different hyper
parameter configurations and and all
these kinds of things so something to
take into account now the second type of
feature selection method is what's
called a filter method and the
interesting thing about filter methods
is that they are actually sort of
learning independent they do not use a
linear model or a random force or
anything like this to figure out what
what if a feature contains information
is relevant to your target variable it
just it uses a statistical measure of
some source to just figure out hey does
this variable add any information to the
set of variables I already have so a
very very very simple example of this
would be I have my rate said let's just
compute the correlation for every and
every variable between every variable
and my target variable and keep the ones
that have a correlation hired and let's
say point eight or something like this
right that would be a very very very
simple example but I don't really want
to talk about that about a simple
examples here so what what I want to do
is I want to go a little bit into the
details of one specific
specific instance of these filter
methods and it's an algorithm that is
based on a measure that is called mutual
information so if you don't know what
mutual information is I've displayed it
here but really what you need to know is
again it is a measure that tries to
quantify how much information one
variable contains that is relevant for
the other variable you can compute it
through this integral but really what
you need to know the higher the mutual
information the more variable X the more
information variable X contains that is
relevant for variable Y so in the
context of feature selection what we
really want to do is like make that
number as high as possible right like
let's think X is the set of features we
care about and why is there it's a
target variable of interest we want to
make that mutual information as high as
possible because those features X should
explain the target variable Y so that is
really like what we want to do in our
under feature selection program right
like we wanna again just to reiterate we
want to we want to select the set of
variables that such that this quantity
is met is maximized so that seems
straightforward but it isn't because the
problem is that this is an np-hard
problem because the set of possible
combinations of features you can
consider grows exponentially so you
cannot like just it's very only like
very basic instances you can solve this
thing exactly so what we really need to
do is resort to URIs takes resort to
approximation methods of some kind so
very you'll find that in if you if you
dive into the literature you'll find
that a very popular heuristic is to is
to use a greedy search algorithm and
what you do is it's very similar to the
ML extent example that I just showed is
incrementally we're gonna incremental e
we're going to add one feature at a time
and the feature we're going to add is
the one that that sort of is going to
give us the highest increase in this it
is joint mutual information term we were
looking at so really this just this just
formalized is that right we have we have
a collection of the very at the given
iteration we have a collection of
variables that we've already selected
now we want to add another variable to
that set and we do that in such a way
that
I such that this this mutual information
term is maximised still we not to
compute this thing still this is very
very hard so what you can show and I'm
not gonna show that here because that's
really our scope protection not that
hard to do it is that you can decompose
that term as follows and the nice thing
is now that here and this term is still
problematic because as t minus 1 is
still a t minus 1 dimensional integral
so you can imagine that as the number of
iterations grow as we we iterate further
further and further it's gonna become
harder and harder and harder and
impossible to actually calculate this
thing so what you will find is that to
actually still do this you will still
need to come up with some kind of
approximation to these two two terms and
how people tend to do that is by
basically assuming some kind of linear
combination of univariate mutual
information terms to approximate that
big multi-dimensional integral and that
are constants I'll get to them in a
minute so bear with me but the nice
thing about is about these filter
methods that that try to reduce with
mutual information based measures is
that you you cannot sort of see the sort
of trade-off appearing because the term
on the left-hand side where I wrote
relevancy tries to measure how relevant
a given feature is to the to of the
target variable of interest so that's
the relevancy term but this term is
basically a correction term what it
tries to do is okay I have this feature
that are potentially want to add to my
existing feature set but let's measure
how much information that I already have
in the set of features that I selected
is also contained
new feature so he's really trying to
trade up okay how much new information
is my variable gonna add versus how much
of that new information is actually
already present in a set of variables
that I've already selected and often
better you can control that kind of
trade-off and he will see that actually
these parameters they parameterize a
whole family of mutual information based
methods so if you just take the averages
so if you may and the criteria you then
get is what's called the joint mutual
information criterion but you can
actually play this around because
because this is like again this is
another tricky term to compute so if you
are fine with sort of ignoring this
conditional dependency you can set this
to zero that's actually what's called
the maximum relevancy minimum redundancy
Kitaen because you try to maximize you
know the relative a given variable to
the target of interest versus how much
information is actually redundant in it
variable and then finally you can also
just set you know set these constants
constants to zero and really only do
relevancy maximization which is not in
my opinion the best fit the best thing
to do but you know give maybe you're
maybe you are time constraint namely
your computation computationally
constrained then this is another method
you can do and this is actually like the
lower one is the one you will be able to
find in scikit-learn so this is it but
so I want to get into the details of the
of this album just to sort of give you a
flavor of what is going on but really
what I wanted what I think the most
important message message of this is is
if you look at this mutual information
based measures for for a filter based
feature selection what they try to do is
is sort of trade-off the relevancy of a
variable versus the redundancy of the
information in that variable and you can
actually control that that trade-off
which is which is something
quite like so again you don't have to
implement all these all these formulas
by yourself there are actually many like
implementations out there there's so
short but there's a that's a package
called site - feature which gives you a
scikit-learn like API and it actually it
actually implements all these criteria
that I just mentioned the whole family
and actually a lot more things as well
so definitely worth a look then there's
another package called M ifs which
stands for mutual information
mutual information based feature
selection which also it's just another
implementation of this specific type of
algorithm and scikit-learn obviously
also has its bone range of feature
selection algorithms some of which are
featured a filter based feature
selection methods and finally you have
an ell extent which also has these kind
of methods in in place so as you can see
like they're actually like a number of
different module modules out there that
you can use use they all have this I
could learn like API so it's very if
you're comfortable with that already
it's very easy to just plug this stuff
into your existing pipeline so again
like we're comment we're coming back to
this to this slide right we have we have
feature selection algorithms you can
divide them into three categories
wrapper methods filter methods and
embedded methods and we've talked about
wrapper methods which are purely
performance based and we've talked about
filter methods which are almost like the
opposite we you know you do not use a
learner to you to to figure out what
what irrelevant variables are but you
use some kind of statistical measure
whether that is correlation or mutual
information or some other kind of
measure you have but it's learning
independence so that that's kind of like
its advantage it's like independent of
learning algorithm it tends to to secure
a little bit better - higher - higher
dimensional methods although there's
definitely a trade-off here especially
in the context of what I discussed just
now with like the multi-dimensional
integrals but at the same time I think
it's strength the the fact it's
independent of the learning algorithm
can also be its weakness you know it so
again it really depends on the use case
at hand like if you really care about
performance if that's all you really
care about them maybe you kind of want
that interaction to be part of it which
is which is actually like a nice
follow-up to the the final class of
future selection methods these embedded
methods because they are sort of they
sort of live in between rapper and
filter methods what a meta methods
they're like there's a big group of
techniques that basically do feature
selection as part of the model
construction model construction process
you know you can think about a random
force kind of doing or a lasso model I
think a lot of models actually like a
better example that kind of does it as
well like you you you you you train a
model you try to look at the you tune
pyramids in such a way that you get
optimal performance of some sorts but it
does feature selection as part of its as
part of its learning through the l1
penalty you put on the coefficients but
I don't want to talk about lots of
because I think like we're all quite
familiar so I want to take it like one
little step further and discuss a method
that I actually have found I actually
have found pretty useful and this is
called as a method called stability
selection so what is stability selection
it is it is it is an algorithm that
wraps around an existing algorithm much
like a random force actually does write
a random force as is basically like more
estimating a decision tree which is your
base learner or multiple like boots of
samples of your original a stability
selection actually is actually not that
dissimilar from from this approach what
it what happens is you have to the
intersection it wraps around the another
algorithm the the one thing that other
algorithm needs is is some kind of
parameter that controls the amount of
regularization you put on the problem
and I'm gonna like so I am gonna use the
lasso and it's more in this example but
actually like stability selection is a
it's a is an algorithm that is actually
like its model independence so you can
do it you can do this you can do it on
lasso you can use it on orthogonal
matching pursuit algorithms in theory
you can even you can you do it on
gradient boost the trees and all this
kind of stuff so it's actually like
quite model model agnostic but it was
introduced in a context of lots of
models it was introduced in the context
of genetic problems where you typically
have very low sample size and a very
high dimensional data set but but you
get back but to get back to the
algorithm itself
so you had so you have a base learner
and what the water-based learning does
for every value of the penalization
parameter you basically get a set of
variables back right so think about math
so for a given valent value of the of
the l1 penalty you're going to get a set
of variables that the lasso model
actually deems relevant for your
particular problem so here it's exactly
the same so what does to build
intersection - it takes that based
learner and it runs it like around for
us it generates many bootstrap samples
of your original or of your original
dataset and it's gonna run your base
learner for for a grid of values of the
opinions Asian parameter that you have
on every bootstrap sample so you really
like you're gonna and and this is why I
actually you want this base learning
algorithm to be computationally cheap
right because you're gonna they're going
to estimate this model from many many
many many times actually and really and
what you sort of do is because you get
the boot subsample for every value of
the penalization parameter you get a set
of variables that is relevant so what
you can then do is compute basically you
keep track of which variables get
selected and you can actually compute
some kind of like probability of your
variable being selected or your variable
being relevant so really like I hope I
hope the diagram makes what I what I'm
just describing to you in words a bit
clearer but really what happens is right
you have we do we iterate who have a
good example and for every value of the
cumulation parameter what we do is we
generate the bootstrap we estimate we
estimate a lot so model we keep track of
the features that get selected this we
do many many many times once we're done
we can actually compute compute
probability or conclusion and then we
sort of select a set of variables that
exceeds some kind of threshold and the
idea so what is really the idea behind
this method right the idea is that you
typically have a high dimensional
dataset you want to really want to
figure out which variables are really
really relevant for my problem what I do
is I create gel I create many copies of
my original problem and I inject noise
in every in in every copy of that
problem that is what the bootstrapping
in a very similar way as to what random
forests do and the idea is that hey I
variables that are relevant are
variables that are kind of show that are
gonna be deemed things relevant in every
one of those subproblems even even
though there is extra random noise
injected into that problem so that
that's really idea in the presence of
all this all this injected noise which
variables are variables are still
relevant so actually like it is actually
quite straightforward to implement this
kind of model because it's really just
like generating some boots of samples
and estimating model many many many
times so I've just like outlines a base
like implementation here so really what
the idea is right we look we iterate
through we iterate through a number of
like boots of samples what what do we do
right is the first part we generate a
bunch of sample we set reset the the
tuning time we set the one penalty and
then we we track with we train the model
and in the end we keep track of only the
variables that actually actually get
selected and then to actually compute
the score it is a very simple meeting
over over to pull over the proportion of
how often these variables get selected
so this is a there's a homegrown
implementation I just wanted to show it
to you we show to you that is actually
like very again straightforward to
implement this there are better
implementations out there especially if
you look at because especially we look
at are like are are so strong following
in in in genetic so there's a package
called stops which stands for stability
selection and they vary like therefore
they have a pretty decent implementation
in there then there is then there's also
a Python module called skg GM which what
it really tries to it again it has
actually a cycle an API but what it what
it deals with is basically basically
Gaussian graphical models but as part of
that whole suite of methods that are
relevant for that class of models they
actually also have an implementation of
this stability solution procedure so
again again the methods are out there
right and everything and it's quite nice
that as a community we've sort of like
converge on this like you learn API
so it's very easy to just plug and play
with these kind of components so I would
definitely recommend to order to have a
look at at these methods now okay so now
we're here basically this is this is
basically what I wanted to do with you
today I wanted to give you a full view
of the sort of type of feature selection
methods that are available and sort of
highlighted if the highlight one what
they do to give you a give you an idea
of what algorithms in that specific
class look like and three if you're
feeling of the advantages and
disadvantages of these methods but
really at the left and the left if you
if you look about if you think about it
you're reprimanded that are purely like
performance based your filter methods
were sort of on the opposite end of the
spectrum who are not really performance
based but really think about it in more
statistical terms and you have embedded
methods that sort of sit in the middle
of these two like classes of methods and
it really depends on the use case it
depends on the use case you have it
depends on the data your the data you
have how much data you have and all
these kinds of things as to which like
method is best for you again as always
there's no there's no silver bullet no
snow one method to rule them all but
it's it's but but at least this gives
you sort of an idea of okay these are
the strengths of these methods if I want
performance I need I will probably want
to look here if not maybe I want to look
here etc etc which kind of brings me
actually to the other end of end of this
presentation right it's like this just
read this just reiterates what I was
just saying like I think very very
generally speaking filter methods tend
to be a bit faster than embedded methods
and embedded methods tend to be a bit
faster than than reprimands just because
repre methods you know they estimates a
model for every different configuration
of the variables you have and in terms
of over in in terms of overfitting
you'll find that you know wrapper
methods they live higher like learning
capacity because they a day and there
and therefore therefore they're a bit
more likely to overfit and embedded
methods which are a bit more likely to
offer it and filter messages because
filter methods tend to be tend to not be
connected to the learning
you're actually actually looking at but
again this this is very generally
speaking and it really depends on a
specific use case as Han because I'm
talking about overfitting but if you're
really in a case where you have large
and large amounts of data in terms of
sat on the number of samples this
overfitting risks becomes you know
there's there's less of that that can at
that kind of risk whereas if you are in
a low in a in a low sample size case the
risk is actually much much much higher
and which is also why like if you think
about how I tend to use these methods I
give them in a low sort of low sample
size size case I came to look at filter
methods and embedded methods whereas if
I have a lot of data I tend to more look
at embedded methods and wrapper
raptor methods so really that's all like
I wanted to do today I just wanted to
get again give you a feeling for these
methods I hope the message hit home and
if there are any questions I'm more than
happy to answer them now thank you
[Music]
I think I think it's very interesting
question so I think it's a bit 2-fold
because initially I found that I still
mean to do that just to make them a
little bit happy but the kind of power
is then that I do that I apply these
methods and then I show them there's
only a very tiny portion of their data
is actually either relevant or in such a
good enough shape that it's typically
the latter like because the data so
poorly collected that that is actually
relevant and then you find it in the
follow-up after that then I can actually
I have more credibility in that sense to
just say hey we did this in the past
this is not how it works we should first
focus dooming and a couple of things we
are priority very very relevant start
from there and then see if we can add
and all that's typically my my approach
to discuss follows sorry yeah
yes so so if you think about it it
should it should actually not be really
be a problem because it's mutual
information term when it becomes with
categorical variable it becomes a sum so
it's actually much better for you to be
honest so we'll find it with the fill in
the filter methods case it just depends
on the measure
so mutual information based measures
find correlation not so fine right and
then if you think about the embedded
methods and the wrapper methods they are
based on the learning algorithm so it's
really up to like can your learning
algorithm properly deal with the
categorical variables and then you're
good yes or no so in the case of
stability is like sheer totally fine
because it's a lhasa model and it can
that totally goes well with categorical
variables so it's then that that becomes
more important so I totally see what
you're saying so I do think my answers
gonna be very simple it's similar though
because it's a wrapper and embedded
methods it's about the learning
algorithm so it's about the capacity of
that algorithm can I deal with this
these variables of high cardinality and
I think the question is the filter
method so I've actually not not tried
these methods on that kind of problem
[Music]
the whole thing and not just that the
one indicates that one level now I I'm
totally with you I'm totally with you so
no no but the filter methods will do it
actually because it just again depends
on how you construct your original data
set but if you if you keep it as let's
say one column in that sense it is one
integral that it's measuring and it
computes integral by looking at all
those different levels and and it's not
even a heart integral to compute because
it becomes a sum because it's it's this
because it's discrete so like even even
if you very high cardinality that should
totally be doable
so actually I so in all honesty I've not
used it on those kind of problems but I
actually think it should not fulfill to
for this particular type of filter
method I don't think it should be a
problem you can because it just becomes
what it still becomes an integral of
that variable of high cardinality with
the target variable that's fine and for
the repair and better methods it depends
on the on the learning algorithm that
would be my answer cool all right thank
you everybody or sorry yeah
so as so it's the question then that you
you have four data sets and it's a
question then did I try first doing some
unsupervised methods who maybe learn
some kind of embedding and then the
feature selection on the embedding its
so yeah I've so I've not done that so
I've not done that myself I don't see
reason why I would not work the only
thing is is it becomes hard to then link
it back I think to your original dataset
depending on like the unsupervised
method you use right and so I think that
would be my own like my I think it's to
me it sounds like this is totally doable
but again but this is the only like
piece of the puzzle which for me for me
personally would be a problem because
like I tend to have to explain like what
happens in my model so if I don't have
this unsupervised block in the middle it
becomes kind of tricky to link it i
think it back but in principle i I don't
think this should be a problem but I
firstly not explored it myself yet
yeah yeah so this is this definitely
happen to me this is a very tricky
situation so it really becomes more
soft-skills problem how do you
communicate this to apply it how do you
how do you manage that so typically like
I've definitely encountered this
typically what happens is we do a couple
of follow-up analysis analysis is all
you're looking at that variable in
particular ever trying to understand
okay is what we're seeing is that truly
correct is it is it one truly that
variable does not add any information or
is it that the information that we
fought this present in this variable is
actually already present in other set of
variables that we actually have selected
right because if it's that case then
we're kind of never kind of done it we
have an explanation for it and if it's
not that then really what we need to do
is we need to dive into that variable
and try to understand okay a priori
father was very relevant why is it not
relevant so then it becomes this
investigation Thanks
you